there are a lot more publishers of comic
books than just the big dogs of Marvel
and DC let's not forget about Valiant
Comics originators of badass heroes with
silly names like Man O'War nin Jack the
eternal warrior and bloodshot while
Marvel and DC have done a very good job
of launching their properties from the
page to the big screen Hollywood has
been slow to grant a valiant character
their own feature film that's all about
to change because a bloodshot movie is
on the way created by Kevin Van Hook Don
Perlin and Bob Layton in 1992 bloodshot
a seemingly unkillable and invincible
scientifically restructured super
trouper has sold more than 7 million
comics since his debut there's clearly
an audience for a bloodshot movie and
Sony has finally decided to make it
happen here's everything you need to
know about the film which is sure to be
action-packed over-the-top and drenched
in buckets of blood come on it's in the
name years ago the only time film goers
got a chance to see big expensive
dazzling and action-packed movies at the
Cineplex was the summer the hottest
months of the year were reserved for
summer blockbusters huge and extravagant
feast for the senses starring
Hollywood's most popular actors
appetites for these movies proved so
high that studio started releasing them
well before summer and now in the dead
of winter two of the most recent and
biggest ever comic book based films hit
movie theaters in mid-february Deadpool
and black panther
it's almost like Marvel has cornered the
comic book movie market and its
competitors should just give up or
something
are you done are you are you done
kidding kidding sort of anyway movie
fans need some alternatives to the other
stuff that dominates movie theaters in
the early months of the year and 2020
we'll continue this trend bloodshot was
initially scheduled to be released over
the weekend of February 21st 2020 Sony
confirmed the date with the film's first
trailer which hit the Internet in
October 2019 in December however the
studio announced that bloodshot had been
pushed back just
few weeks to March 13th obviously one
man action squad Vin Diesel is the
biggest name attached to the upcoming
film adaptation of the bloodshot comics
heading up the cast is Ray garrison
deceased marine turned reborn
overpowered soldier supreme how
nanomachines son
that's how guy Pierce best known for his
role in memory oriented thriller memento
is playing dr. Emil Harding I think
outside the box mad scientist's leading
the experiments on garrison Sam heughan
the breakout star of stars time travel
period peace Outlander is said to be
playing Jimmy Dalton a Navy SEAL and
super soldier in his own right
ASA Gonzales perhaps best known for
playing darling and baby driver stars as
the mysterious MS KT a member of the
inner circle of a strange underground
organization she's joined by longtime
New Girl star lamorne Morris who fills
the comic relief role of Wilfred Wiggins
judging by the first trailer there looks
to be a lot going on in the film version
of bloodshot Vin Diesel is introduced as
a humble marine named Ray it all seems
to be going well as he reunites with his
beloved wife Gina in a lovely seaside
town only to wake up in a cold and dark
research facility connected to a bunch
of machines
matrix-style ray learns from resident
scientist dr. Emil Harding that he
actually died as did Gina but he's now
under the watchful eye of rst a
corporation that rebuilds US military
assets a shadowy corporation with access
to cutting-edge science trying to create
super soldiers huh
we're sure they won't have any you know
ulterior motives or anything oh yeah
scratch that turns out that Ray is the
first successful result of an ongoing
program to remake and enhance soldiers
into living weapons Harding and his
associates have injected into Ray's
blood some out-there technology that
makes them virtually indestructible
extra strong and able to heal from
basically any injury within seconds
with these powers in mind Rey sets out
to take care of unfinished business and
get vengeance on the man who killed his
wife to make a long story short
bloodshot is a lot like Deadpool you
know it has always been a dream of mine
to see my face reflected at your helmet
is you charging me with murderous intent
only super super serious and without any
breaking through the fourth wall there's
also an added psychological complication
as rst just might be manipulating Rey
into pursuing its interests not his own
in other words his memories may not be
what he thinks they are behind the
scenes bloodshot boasts a creative team
with a wealth of entertainment
experience Studios generally don't hand
the reins of a big-budget extravaganza
to brand-new directors that's exactly
what's happening with Dave Wilson
it's his first feature-length project
building upon an episode of the sci-fi
anthology love death and robots and a
long career directing trailers for major
video game releases including the Elder
Scrolls online Mass Effect 2 and Star
Wars The Old Republic Knights of the
Fallen Empire bloodshot's credits list
to screenwriters Jeff Wadlow
and Eric Heiser er Vlad Lowe wrote a
couple of episodes of Bates Motel before
penning the scripts for Comics
adaptation kick-ass 2 the spy farce true
memoirs of an international assassin and
the scary truth or dare hi sir we gotta
start in horror writing the UH Nightmare
on Elm Street remake before working on
the scripts for innovative sci-fi hits
like arrival and bird box in today's
movie world it's all about comic books
superheroes and cinematic universes
Disney has its Marvel Cinematic Universe
and Warner Brothers has DC now Sony may
be in the early stages of getting a
valiant based world of interconnected
characters off the ground using
bloodshot as its Iron Man esque first
chapter according to a Hollywood
Reporter news item from 2015 Sony had
plans to make five valiant adaptations
to bloodshot movies plus two based on
Harbinger a comic about a superhero
collective on the lam from a shady
organization after that the properties
would receive their own Justice League
or Avenger style capper with a crossover
called
our Binger Wars additionally in 2018
Sony hired American Gods adaptation
writer Maria Melnick for a screenplay
about the slightly meta valiant
character faith herbart aka
Zephyr a comics aficionado who becomes a
hero herself when a telekinetic powers
surface it's hard to say if this plan is
still in the cards and a lot rests on
bloodshot being a success
Harbinger moved from Sony to Paramount
in September 2019 which could delay the
development of this particular cinematic
universe only time and blood shots box
office results will tell check out one
of our newest videos right here plus
even more looper videos about your
favorite movies and TV shows are coming
soon subscribe to our YouTube channel
and hit the belt so you don't miss a
single one